I know what my father was what he did I
know the Mad King earned his name kill
every Targaryen get my answer
everyone who wasn't
is an enemy
so is it bring these hands what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another game i throwing season 8
prediction video before i get started i
just want to briefly mention the new
giveaway that i'm doing some of you may
not have seen my last video but i am
giving away two different prizes to two
different winners if you are interested
in entering the giveaway make sure you
stay until the end of the video and i
will go over all the details then now
today i want to talk about the
importance of the Valyrian steel dagger
which is also known as the cat's paw
dagger i haven't made a video about this
yet so i figured it was time to give
this weapon a little more attention now
that the night king is south of the wall
with his entire army Valyrian steel when
dragon clasps are more important now
than they have ever been before simply
because we know these are the type of
weapons that are needed to defeat the
white walkers and possibly even the
night king as of right now Arya Stark is
currently in possession of this dagger
but it was first introduced all the way
back in season 1 episode 2 it was
actually one of the very first Valyrian
steel weapons that were introduced into
the story
besides how Starks Valyrian steel sword
ice lets go into a little bit of the
backstory about this blade the first
time we saw this dagger was shortly
after Jaime Lannister pushed a brain
stark from the tower window after brain
Stark's lifeless body was found on the
ground he was taken to his bed where he
remained in a coma for quite some time
when it became known that brain stark
did not die from his fall someone sent
an assassin to his bedroom to finish off
the job right before the cat's paw
enters brains bedroom someone started a
fire as a way to distract everyone
inside of the castle that way brain
would hopefully be left alone but as we
all know lady Catelyn was not about to
leave brains room just because of a fire
so when the assassin found his bedroom
he was in for a big surprise because
Catelyn wasn't about to just sit by and
watch her son's throat be slit
after a short struggle over the blade
summer comes into the room and rips the
man's throat to pieces at the time it
seemed pretty obvious that someone must
have hired this man to kill bran not
only is Valyrian steel very expensive
but
even if you can't afford it people
aren't interested in selling their
weapons made out of this rare steel you
could tell that the assassin did not
have the kind of money to purchase a
weapon like this on his own I remember
when I saw this episode for the first
time I assumed it had to have been Jamie
or Cersei that hired him since they did
have a motive to want the silenced brand
the second attempt to take brains life
did cause Catelyn to go all the way down
to King's Landing to inform Ned of her
suspicions Catelyn secretly meets with
Ned inside of Littlefinger's brothel and
this is where Littlefinger actually
admits the dagger was his well he says
it was his until he lost it to Tyrion
Lannister in a bed Ned Stark keeps the
dagger with him in King's Landing but
this does lead to Catelyn Stark
arresting Tyrion at the end at the
crossroads which basically kicked off
the war of the five kings once Catelyn
Stark arrested Tyrion Lannister the
story really started to gain some
momentum then as Catelyn has taken
Tyrion to the Eyrie to stand trial
Tyrion explains that he had nothing to
do with the plot to kill brand at the
time I did believe him because what he
said made perfect sense why would Tyrion
send an assassin with his own blade and
even after seven seasons we never truly
find out who sent this blade to kill
bran the last time the dagger was seen
was in season 1 when Ned Stark had the
dagger sitting on his desk in King's
Landing in the books Littlefinger takes
the dagger off the desk and he actually
uses it to arrest Ned Stark but in the
show Littlefinger is using a different
dagger when he holds it to his throat
you can see that the blade is nowhere
near the same but we know Littlefinger
did have the blade the whole time anyway
I don't think this really came as a
surprise to anyone because in season 4
we did learn that Littlefinger actually
set all of these conflicts in motion
Littlefinger was wanting to cause a war
between the Starks and the Lannisters
because he's a piece of [ __ ] while Jaime
Lannister is a stark prisoner after the
Battle of the whispering wood he admits
to pushing brain out of the window but
he denies trying to have brand killed by
an assassin Jamie tries to prove this by
saying Littlefinger said he lost the
dagger to Tyrion betting against Jaime
and Joffrey's tornament but we all know
Tyrion
would never bet against Jamie then Jamie
says he actually remembers that
Littlefinger did lose the dagger in a
bed but he lost it to King Robert
Baratheon not Tyrion and later in the
novels when Joffrey received widow's
wail as a wedding gift he mentions being
familiar with Valyrian steel
this leads Tyrion to suspect that it was
actually Joffrey who attempted to have
bran killed as a sadistic way to impress
Robert who he did think was his father
since Joffrey was known to be a
Baratheon he would have had access to
the dagger and he was in Winterfell at
the same time the assassin would have
been hired however they never do any of
this in the television show
so the dagger remains a mystery until
this very day but now that it has popped
back up in this story you have to wonder
what other roles that might have
specifically regarding the end game of
Game of Thrones as of right now I don't
think they brought the dagger back into
the show so they could explain who
attempted to have brain killed back in
season 1 mostly because now that brain
is the new three-eyed Raven he really
doesn't give a [ __ ] about all of that
Bryon's focus is on the knight king and
how to defeat him Littlefinger
possessing the dagger openly - bran
makes it seem unlikely that the show
will alter the book storyline and make
Littlefinger the person who tried to
kill bran
mainly because the bran would have seen
that coming and because Littlefinger has
never shown any signs of wanting to have
Kaitlyn's children killed however then
reintroducing this dagger this late in
the game seems like they may have done
that for a good reason
during season 7 the dagger did pop up in
a very unexpected place in the season
premiere Dragonstone Samwell Tarly reads
a book about the long night and this is
when he discovers there is a mountain of
dragonglass under Dragonstone while he's
reading we catch a glimpse of what
appears to be the cats ball dagger on
one of the pages and there is also some
text written on those pages and it says
the Valerians were familiar with
dragonglass long before they came to
Westeros they called it frozen fire in
Valeria in eastern tales tell of how
their dragons with all the stone wood
dragon flame until it became molten and
malleable the Valerians then you
to build their strange monuments and
buildings without seams and joints of
our modern castles when Aegon the
conquerer forged his Seven Kingdoms he
and his descendants would often decorate
their blades with dragonglass feeling a
kinship with this stone the royal
fashion for dragonglass ornamentation
soon spread throughout the Seven
Kingdoms to those wealthy enough to
afford it
hilts and pall malls were and are the
most common decoration for dragonglass
if too brittle to make a useful cross
card indeed it's very brittleness is
what relegated it to the great houses
and the most successful burnt ins so as
you can see this shows that this dagger
does have a deep-rooted history in
Westeros but you also have to ask
yourself how did Littlefinger end up
with something like this
Littlefinger was in possession of this
dagger before the series even began
which leads to him losing the dagger in
a bet to Robert Baratheon beautiful
weapons like these are usually passed
down from generation to generation and
they usually stay within the same house
for hundreds of years but as we all know
Littlefinger does not come from a very
rich or powerful house Littlefinger
actually had to create his own sigil
which was the mockingbirds so it's not
like this dagger was given to him by his
father or grandfather also you have to
wonder why a Valyrian steel dagger would
be in the same book about dragonglass
unless it has something to do with the
second paragraph on the page Sam was
looking at it says when Aegon Targaryen
forged to the Seven Kingdoms he and his
descendants would decorate their weapons
with dragonglass this cat's fall dagger
could have actually been Aegon Targaryen
x'
and that red ruby might actually be red
dragonglass
that would explain why this dagger was
featured in a book that also talked
about where dragon glass was located and
coincidentally enough the dragon glass
was located where Aegon Targaryen had
that big map of Westeros carved into the
table if the illustration is an example
of a Targaryen decorated dagger and not
a dragon glass dagger
that would suggest that the cats ball
dagger isn't just a Valyrian steel
weapon that is capable of being used
against White Walkers but it's also a
Targaryen relic from the times of Aegon
the conquerer those are two direct
connections to the Targaryen 's now this
is very interesting because now all of
this connects to Jon Snow because as we
all know Jon's real name is actually a
gone Targaryen too if this dagger is
really a Targaryen family heirloom then
that means it would technically belong
to Daenerys or John since they are the
only two Targaryen is alive that we know
of as of right now we do not know what
this daggers official name was but I
would bet it has something to do with
the Targaryen especially since to the
hilt is made out of dragon bone this
entire dagger has properties that are
connected to the Dragons the blade is
obviously made out of Valyrian steel
which is forged by dragon's fire the
handle is made out of dragon bone and
the red gemstones might actually be
dragonglass which is basically frozen
dragon fire it's awfully strange that
this dagger just all of a sudden popped
back up after seven seasons right at the
same time that John and Daenerys were
meeting each other and now the dagger is
in Winterfell which is exactly where
John and Daenerys are heading we know
Sam was reading the book that had
information about this dagger so I'm
hoping Sam will notice it on arias hip
then he can give us a more the back
story about this Valyrian steel blade
but I'm also wondering if Littlefinger
stole this blade from someone at the
turning of Harrenhal since that
tournament was such an important moment
in this story I wonder if that's where
Littlefinger got his hands on it since
so many torge Aryans were there this
blade might have been passed down
through the Targaryen line ever since
Aegon conquered Westeros and maybe the
Mad King or Rhaegar took it to the
tourney and that's when Littlefinger
stole it
because I really don't know how else
Littlefinger would have obtained
something like this but that's only a
guess either way the storks have
possession of it now and I would love to
see Arya kill some White Walkers with
this dagger but I'm also wondering if
John will somehow end up with this
blade if it was originally owned by
Aegon the conquerer I would not be
surprised if our current Aegon Targaryen
ends up within since Jon Snow gave Ari a
needle back in season 1
maybe she returns the favor by giving
John the dagger now I would actually
prefer if Arya used it in the great war
herself since John already has long Paul
to use but this would not be the first
time weapons were passed off for
different people to use what does
everyone else make of the fact that this
dagger reappeared in this show at this
specific point of the story do you think
we're gonna find out that it belonged to
the Targaryen x' and if it was a Gon's
do you think jon will end up with it
somehow I believe it has another role to
play in the story other than just
killing Littlefinger but let me know
what you think also let me know where
you think Littlefinger acquired this
dagger because that could be an
interesting story in itself now just in
case you did not see my last video let
me tell you about the new giveaway that
I'm doing real quick like I said at the
beginning of the video I am giving away
two different prizes to two different
people both names will be randomly
selected and the first person's name
that gets selected will get to choose
between both prizes I have the complete
Game of Thrones series on blu-ray and I
have the complete a Song of Ice and Fire
book collection the first person's name
that is picked will get to choose
between which one they want and the
second name that is picked will get
whatever prize is left over if you would
like to enter the drawing just use one
of the links that are down below one
will be in the description and the other
one will be in the comment section you
are able to enter multiple times if you
would like that way you can't increase
your chances of winning good luck and
thank you all for watching my videos and
supporting my channel I really
appreciate that
have a great day everyone I will see you
again very soon bye
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you